[Music]  the corporate model is the oldest and  most efficient structure history has  ever shown us scheduled scarcity is a  premium feature of colonial life the  colony must never lose faith that is  what the board provides security in a  senseless and chaotic world  this is Halcyon the furthest colony in  the galaxy  proudly owned and operated by  corporations everything we have  everything we are we owe to them  they are always with us no one has ever  gone against them  but a stranger has just arrived  someone who's challenging the corporate  board  someone who's digging up their secrets  [Music]  someone who could be a villain or a hero  looks like the bleeding stopped I owe  you one here hope this gun serves you  better than it did me or a psychopath Oh  my touch shine  good luck  I suppose time will tell but no matter  who this stranger chooses to be the  house the own colony will never be the  same  [Music]  all their lackeys they're all a bunch of  swine